uh this next story you know I I feel
sort of extra sad about this only
because we've been covering it from the
beginning uh anti-vaccine pro-trump
right wing radio host Phil Valentine who
had been in the hospital with kovid for
some time now has died
and we started to wonder if things were
taking a turn for the worst some time
ago because we were hearing from his
family he's not exactly turning the
corner and Phil Valentine has now died
we covered this from the very beginning
there's a rolling stone article laying
it out which explains a few days after
Phil Valentine announced he had tested
positive for covid-19 on July 11th the
conservative talk show host wrote on
Facebook he was doing my patriotic Duty
for natural herd immunity sort of
suggesting the way to get through this
is for people to get sick and recover
and develop herd immunity this was a
pretty big radio host he had a national
show on 100 stations for 12 years he
openly questioned vaccines on his show
he mocked the vaccination campaign with
a song vax Man parodying The Beatles
Taxman he said I am certainly not
getting the vaccine now he said on July
14th saying I have full Immunity on the
basis of his positive coveted diagnosis
he is now dead at 61.
and as we had been following his
condition worsened steadily since being
diagnosed he was in the hospital a full
two weeks and then placed on a
ventilator on July 30th his brother said
he was being transferred to an ECMO
machine which is now we're talking not
just ventilation we're talking a machine
that does the work of the heart and
lungs
Phil Valentine wrote on Facebook on July
13th you need to have a plan in case you
get covered make sure you get your
vitamin D3 level checked and have a
doctor on speed dial listen to this who
will write you a prescription for
Ivermectin
Ivermectin is a drug
used to treat livestock heifers horses
mares
Etc
for worms and this is what some
have been advocating for you've seen it
on Fox News you've seen it elsewhere
um Phil valentine's saying if you're at
high risk of dying from covid I still
strongly suggest you consider the
vaccine
just make sure you're prepared if you
decide against the vaccine
I'm not going to go on and on and on
talking about all the different things
that Phil Valentine said but needless to
say he is now dead from coronavirus now
um we heard from uh Republican senator
Marsha Blackburn
Republican senator Marshall Blackburn
tweeted about this and she said Phil
Valentine was a Visionary for the
conservative movement
and he made an enormous impact on the
lives of many tennesseans my deepest
condolences and prayers are with Phil's
wife Susan and his family may they be
comforted and surrounded by love during
this difficult time you know I would
really respect Senator Marsha Blackburn
more or at all because I my respect
level for her is zero right now I would
respect her if she used this as an
opportunity to say
get vaccinated this is really serious
Phil was 61 and as far as we know
healthy although I'm not totally sure
and he went out of his way for a while
to say no horse dewormer instead of
vaccines and he's dead now
uh she didn't do that she didn't even
refer to the irresponsible nature of his
anti-vaxx campaign now if we have to
find anything here that maybe we could
say is there any silver lining Phil
Valentine did become pro-vaccine in his
final days and he started encouraging
people around him and messages getting
out through the radio station through
his brother saying he now says go and
get yourself vaccinated it is actually
possible again this is it's a bad
situation but if we can find something
in it it's possible that he will save
some lives by virtue of becoming
pro-vaccine and talking about it to a
crowd that would be disproportionately
vaccine skeptical right Wingers his
audience once he was very sick it didn't
save him and he still promoted the horse
dewormer Ivermectin really dangerous
weaponized stuff but maybe maybe he will
actually be responsible for some lives
saved by virtue of the fact that he lost
his own life statistically
because he did not go and get himself
vaccinated some people get vaccinated
and die but very few
in all likelihood being vaccinated would
have saved his life now he is dead maybe
his followers will follow his most
recent advice which is go and get
yourself vaccinated it's it it's really
reminiscent of the Jonestown Jim Jones
temple stuff like where he's talking
about you know uh uh follow him and if I
told you to drink cyanide laced Kool-Aid
would you and eventually he gave the
cyanide laced cool I mean the Ivermectin
stuff is essentially that at this point
will you on my say so do you trust me
enough that you will take the heart
dewormer which you might have to get
from a veterinarian although there are
some medical doctors that are actually
making it easy for people to get it's
it's crazy what's going on and a little
bit later we'll talk about what's
happening in Mississippi it's a
dystopian covet hellscape in Mississippi
that is getting to or even surpassing
what is happening in Florida Mississippi
and Alabama increasingly the coveted
hellholes of the United States all of
that coming up make sure to let me know
your thoughts you can find me on Twitter
at dpacman and by the way we are now
only five and a half million YouTube
views from one billion YouTube views
when we get to that billion we're gonna
do a huge membership special you can be
notified by getting on my newsletter at
davidpackman.com but what a number 1
billion views coming up really really
soon